Russia's representative pointed out he
was born in the year the Security
Council last met to formally discuss
what was listed on the agenda as the
india-pakistan question I was won in
1971 so I don't know we'll see sometimes
it's better not to touch up on certain
issues the meeting lasted just over an
hour and in the absence of any joint
statement to China's ambassador outlined
the position of his country alone the
Kashmir issue should be resolved
properly through peaceful means in
accordance with the UN Charter the
relevant Security Council resolutions
and bilateral agreements this represents
the international community's consensus
the Indian ambassador quick to argue
that China was claiming consensus when
none exists insisting that any
resolution lies not in international
mediation but in bilateral discussion as
set out in the similar agreement reached
with Pakistan in 1972 we are ready to
address these issues in a manner that
states who have normal approaches to
international ties should address them
and in our case we are committed to the
similar agreement it's now for Pakistan
to make that commitment to stop terror
to start talks Pakistan's ambassador
made clear her country would continue to
press for greater UN involvement
claiming the meeting itself as a victory
in this process the fact that this
meeting took place is testimony to the
fact that this is an internationally
recognized dispute there was an effort
to stop this meeting from convening and
we are grateful to all 15 members of the
UN Security Council for agreeing to
having this meeting in recent days
protesters have gathered outside the UN
building demanding greater international
involvement in the crime
and calling on the UN to enforce its own
resolutions on the Kashmir dispute the
lack of consensus in the Security
Council oblique response offering only
the possibility of another 50-year wait
before the matter is taken up again
mechana al-jazeera United Nations